foreign
's taking quite a toll we know that half
of Americans say their personal
financial situations are worse now than
they were a year ago more than any time
since the Great Recession
but there's something deeper according
to a Gallup survey released Wednesday
which asked a thousand adults across the
U.S about their past and future finances
not only is this the first time since
2008 2009 that at least 50 percent of
Americans report feeling worse off
financially than they were a year ago
it's the only time aside from those two
years that they have that that many
responded negatively since they started
asking questions in 1976. wow and while
economists are still torn on whether
we're heading towards a recession on in
the unemployment rate stands at a
53-year low I just want to put that in
context
when you're having a debate when
academics
um and I don't say that pejoratively
that's that's my background when when
thinkers are saying well is it recession
or is it not is it
that means things haven't fallen off a
cliff that means things are tough things
are messy things are are not as we want
them to be
but is not 2008 and 2009 yeah and it
doesn't take a financial expert we've
got Rising interest rates right
um then we've got the FED jacking with
things and prospective home buyers have
been driven from the market credit card
debt is more expensive public layoffs at
high profile companies like so here's
what I'm hearing Jade
there's a ton of media messages
screaming at everybody telling them that
this is the end of time yep and it's
just not the end of time in fact if you
keep saying it enough
you we will run this sucker into the
ditch and make it the end of time you're
reading my mind right now gotta stop I'm
gonna take a page out of your playbook
turn the news off turn it off turn it
off turn it off because my guy John is
exactly right it's it's it it's playing
into your mindset if you hear that over
and over and over Doom and Gloom Doom
and Gloom we we can't get ahead
inflation it's driving up our grocery
prices and I'm not saying that people
aren't feeling a pinch and that people
aren't struggling I'm not saying that
but there's a difference between going
like just wallowing in that daily
because you start to succumb to to
fearful practice and you start doing
things like taking out helocs and and
thinking oh the only way I'm going to
get a car is to to get a you know I have
to pay this 17 you know 717 dollars a
month it's the only way because car
prices are you know and you start doing
the dumb stuff that goes along with all
of that when it's like okay let me just
let me take a break here yeah and like
pull back and go okay I can't solve
inflation I can't solve what's going on
at the White House I can't solve the job
market but me is a problem I can solve
yep right everything you can solve
that's right and no amount hear me say
this no amount of watching the news is
going to bring down the price of eggs no
amount of watching the news in Doom
scrolling is going to bring down the
prices of gas and so I can go to the
grocery store and listen you know we had
to cut out my house
I hate to even say it bacon you know
what I love more than most things in the
world bacon but it's 111 a package yeah
so I stopped and the moment we like my
wife said hey bake is so expensive and I
was like let's just cut it out man and
what's wrong with that but but here's
the deal once I made that choice any
second I spend thinking about it whining
about it complaining about it watching
the news about it is a choice to be
miserable it's a choice
I just said hey let's let's cut it out
it's too expensive right now I'm then
going on about my day I'm not gonna give
some Media Company the opportunity to
make me miserable does that make sense
that I'm giving you a slope I'm giving
you a slow clap I'm done with it because
I I said the same thing the other day
you go into the grocery store you see
the price of eggs and and you want to go
on social media you want to tell
everybody you know oh my gosh the price
of eggs you want to freak out about it
buy a bagel
sorry can you just buy a bagel yes can
you get some cereal yes that's all I'm
saying do and please don't mishear me
I've got 10 chickens get chickens don't
mishear me there's there's a single mom
that is crying every night that's right
she can't breathe but the majority there
is a vast majority of us we just like to
get on the bandwagon of Crazy Town like
whatever the news is talking about
you're just texting your buddy you're
sending Fox News links I love Fox news
by the way but you're sending Fox News
links to everyone you know the worst
possible stories and they found another
China balloon they found another you
know what does that mean go buy gold
you're like going bananas yeah and all
you're doing is disconnecting yourself
from your family your community your
friends and here's the worst part we're
not solving the problems what if you
just opened up your budget and went okay
deep breath
we're over three hundred dollars where
can we find it okay maybe you know
Susie is is taking piano lessons bass
guitar lessons Jiu Jitsu less maybe we
can cut out one of those for now okay
we're spending this much on groceries
what can we do maybe we can start buying
some bagels maybe we can cool cool it
out or maybe I can pick up a little bit
of extra hours that's right maybe we had
this planned for 2023 we're gonna spend
more time together
life threw us a curveball and so I'm
gonna have to go pick up another Uber
shift for a season that's right we have
to stop buying this thing that we love
we're gonna have to we have to punt that
vacation let's go ahead and tell our
parents now that we're not coming in
this summer for that trip because we
can't afford it we're gonna have to we
were gonna buy a house we want to buy a
house this August so bad it hurts it's
not gonna happen let's just sit in that
sadness let's be broken hard to get
let's go for a long walk together let's
figure it out and then we're gonna see
what it looks like around Christmas of
next year that's right any choice other
than those choices is a choice to be
miserable stop doing that to ourselves
so good John key word that you said it's
a season yeah and it's a season if
anybody listening is like maybe you're
not the one that's like like just loves
Chris some people just love drama can we
just say that maybe you're not the one
that loves drama if you're really going
through it can just hear us say it's a
season it's a season and you'll get
through this I promise you if you just
take a clear head sit down and look at
the controllables and control your
controllables you will get through this
I promise you that and reach out to
folks when you need the help Reach Out
Reach Out Reach Out reach out
um that's that's the other thing I got
and we'll we'll move on because I can
talk about this all day I could too the
more that we are pumping this into our
heads into our eyes and our ears about
how awful everything is it's a natural
psychological tendency I start to my
gaze goes to my own belly button how can
I protect me and mine and when your body
feels like it's scared it quickly it's
instantly it's a protective measure but
it divides the world up between Us's and
thems and I miss that single mom who
can't breathe who's trying to figure out
how to buy groceries because I'm too
busy thinking it's all coming down
instead of keeping my eyes up and
looking at people in my neighborhood and
my community and my grocery line that I
can reach in there and say I got you
ma'am I got you so good and that's what
neighbors do that's what communities do
and the more we're like it's it
everything's on fire it takes a very
special person to override your
psychology and look around for others in
the midst of a fire right so turn the
news off turn the mess off get the news
you need and get out right right get in
get out John what you said is so good if
you're listening to this because some
people are kind of flying above the
storm right now and and that if that's
you that's a great place to be
um we all should aspire to that like
when 2008 comes when covid comes man I
hear Dave say it all the time what a
great place to be when you're just a
spectator yeah right and if you're
listening to the show and you're a
spectator buy somebody's groceries
tonight yeah on the way home on the way
home look at somebody who's trying to
fill up with gas and they're looking
through their purse for coins yeah and
just put your put your debit card in and
get it and ask no questions
Happy Valentine's Day Happy Valentine's
Day that's right start uh stop looking
at your own belly button and start
looking up around at your neighbors man
and you're gonna find a whole different
take on this it's all coming down you
know I I was reading a book day and it
said history doesn't repeat itself
people do
pesto history is this other thing that's
operating I mean we're the ones that
drives it right so and in a in a time
like this I'm like
people what does it say Americans are
feeling worse about their money since
the Great Recession okay
stop doing the dumb things that people
did during the Great recessions don't do
it again
don't be the people who repeat
themselves that makes history repeat
itself you know what I'm saying yep do
something different
hey you know what that's that's the
magic mental health moment
if it's not working stop doing that
thing do something different do
something different we see how this has
played out before let's just do
something different
let's stop choosing misery